I never thought I'd have to make a
YouTube drama video so here we go and by
the way I'm Robert I'm 24 and I run the
channel and I created Super Cuts Delight
I promise I'm not a hacker I'm using my
girlfriend's setup and I don't normally
make these types of videos for this
video I'm going to go through the
timeline of my hackings cuz it happened
three times because a lot of people are
confused and rightfully so and there's
also a lot of controversy in behind the
scenes issues for Google and YouTube
that I discovered during this hacking
that I think will be invaluable for you
to know because if you at all have a
channel then this will be very important
to listen to so the first time I got
hacked I fell for a scam that I thought
was legit unfortunately and I clicked a
link and it was just like a Dropbox link
and I clicked on a text document which
apparently is enough to be hacked so
that probably uploaded some kind of like
uh virus software onto my computer that
allowed them to from what from my
knowledge I think allowed them to hijack
my session login state which by the way
allows them to completely bypass to
factor authentification so no matter how
many security countermeasures you have
they can bypass them by the second time
I was hacked I had literally everything
set up but they were still able to get
in like I would literally just wake up
in the morning and I would just check
notifications on my phone being like
your password was changed your account
recovery was changed your phone number
was changed and I was just like what
they just my account was just wide open
and they just walked in and changed
everything so I guess that they just had
a software that allow them to just
hijack my session ID or whatever I don't
know I'm not a cyber security expert
also this goes into one of the Google
issues in that you can change your
security countermeasures and it won't
ask for like any kind of verification so
as long as they get into your account
they can change everything without any
Security checks which is pretty insane
someone in Russia can log into your
account and change everything and that
won't raise any security concerns like
that's just mind-boggling to me I don't
don't know why Google allows that at the
very least they should require you to
like two Factor authenticate if you want
to change like your phone number or
something I don't know so naturally
being someone who's not very tax happy
about this I just installed two antivir
softwares which said that my computer
was clean and I got a VPN and I was like
all right hopefully this is safe and
then a week went by and I got hacked a
second time by this point I was like
okay something's definitely wrong and I
factory reset my entire computer and
wiped every file off of it which is
pretty rough and I had a consultation
with a cyber security expert now this
goes into one big issue with Google and
that if you get hacked they don't offer
any form of cyber security specialist
for support you're kind of just screwed
in that department and you have to just
go find a cyber security expert no one
at Google helps you all they do is just
recover your accounts they're just like
all right good luck we got your account
account back but we're not going to help
you with that like hacker that's
attacking you so that's pretty rough all
the like all the support literally does
just like they just give you an article
being like try resetting your password
or try turning on two Factor
authentification or like some other tips
and it's just like that's literally not
helping me at all but luckily I was in
the circumstance of knowing someone that
was a cyber security expert so I could
consult with someone so another week
goes by and I get hacked again this is
the third time by the way the second
time the hacker like didn't really do
anything with the channel luckily they
only uploaded like one video about like
cryptocurrency so this third time it's a
mystery I factory reset my computer how
are they getting in so the only thing I
could theorize because I'm not entirely
sure is that they were maybe getting in
through my phone so I factory reset my
phone so every device touching my
channel has been factory reset so up
until this point YouTube has been pretty
Hasty about recovering my account the
first time it happened it took them 7
hours and the second time it happened it
took about 12 to 24 hours which leads to
the third hacking this is where the
controversy and all the issues start to
boil up and get exposed to me so it took
YouTube 20 days to recover my account so
okay there's a lot to unpack here
firstly YouTube is supposed to lock your
account and like disable it so the
hacker can't like tamper with your
channel and like upload and delete
videos that's what they told me they did
they told me that multiple times and I
even asked them to Define what a
disabled account is that's what they
told me basically however that was just
untrue it was false the hacker uploaded
295 videos that's how many I deleted
when I got it back and they were doing
that up until like I don't know December
28th and they started privatizing and
maybe deleting I'm not sure videos like
towards the end of the hack so YouTube
was either just flat out lying to me or
giving me false information and because
of that that drastically damaged my
channel I lost 16,000 subscribers like
that might not seem like a lot because I
have over 350,000 subscribers but those
are active subscribers that are watching
my content and are paying attention to
their subscription feed and YouTube did
nothing like that's just insane to me
and is extremely upsetting like I was
pretty like depressed about it for like
multiple weeks so yeah the YouTube
support specialist was kind of just I
don't know if they were lying to me but
it feels like they were which
notoriously the YouTube support
Specialists have been very not good to
say the least they kind of just Gaslight
you a classic example being like if one
of your videos gets demonetized because
of like extreme profanity it will kind
of get like blacklisted and the support
Specialists always deny this but it's
like hey my I was getting like a th000
views an hour and now it's down to like
10 views an hour surely something is
happening behind the scenes about that
and then they literally gasl let you and
say just make better thumbnails and
better videos forehead that and YouTube
support was not being transparent with
me like at all they would basically just
give me very vague responses like oh
we're working on the issue and by the
two we Mark or so they were finally
admitting that they were running in the
problems and I was like well what
problems are you running into and they
wouldn't give me any specific details so
this kind of Falls in line with like
classic YouTube support who aren't very
helpful and don't like give you clear
and concise information like they were
even giving me copy and pasted responses
in my email chain with them now this is
going into one big final issue about why
it took so long for them to recover my
hack channel so towards the end of the
hack I called Google support I found a
number but it wasn't people who like
were working at YouTube and in this call
the person told me that there's
essentially like a shortage of support
staff during the Christmas holidays
which makes sense but I got hacked
December 11th which is pretty soon
before like Christmas time or at least
like the week of Christmas so this
essentially allowed the hacker to take
hold of my channel for almost three
weeks and this is Google by the way they
make a crap ton of net income every year
just off the top of your head do you
think they make five billion which is a
lot maybe 10 billion no they make like
$60 billion of net income a year and
they can't afford to have support staff
year round making it to where if you're
hacked during the holidays you're kind
of just screwed like that makes the most
sense or maybe because I was hacked
three times they just gave me no
priority at all even though the hacker
was impacting hundreds of thousands of
people with scams like I don't know it
that was just very upsetting to learn
and was probably why it took 3 weeks and
even at the 3- we Mark they offered me a
different kind of solution that was
maybe available the entire time that I
would have rather have done it's just
mind-boggling to me about how they
handled the situation I thought it was
was just atrocious so now this leads to
the implications of what happens to my
channel now which is kind of dire and
scary to me if a hacker uploads 295
videos which viewers rightfully don't
watch and show no interest in and a lot
of people leave the channel how am I
supposed to get them back via YouTube
recommendations of like my new videos
wouldn't the algorithm just kind of bury
my channel for those viewers like why
would they now recommend my new content
like hopefully the YouTube algorithm
actually recommends My Game of Thrones
videos as an example to those viewers
because if they don't then I'm kind of
just screwed I don't know because I do
know some subscribers who just wanted to
unsubscribe because I was nuking their
entire subscription feed with hack
videos so that's definitely
understandable but hopefully some of you
guys find your way back and I am
hopefully back and not going to be
hacked a fourth time which if that
happens then I'm just that's going to be
rough uh so yeah thank you for watching
and if you at all want to support me or
the channel I have a patreon that'll be
in the description if you want to get in
touch with me or just engage with the
channel further in discussions I have a
Discord and I have a letter box for
socials if you want to see more of my
movie reviews and TV shows it's really
unfortunate that this is happening to my
channel and I just want to be left alone
and make videos that you guys enjoy so
yeah hopefully it's better for 2024 for
me and have a Happy New Year